- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is --
- I forgot.
- Wow, I'm sorry, what
was the message (laughs)!
- So the question today is...
Good morning Believe Nation
today's message is --
- Study the business,
over to you, Ross Perot!
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- My advice to a person
who's considering starting
a small business, is number one,
serve an apprenticeship in an industry
you're really excited about.
Let's assume you have a Masters Degree
in Business from Harvard.
Go to work second and third
shift on a factory floor.
Learn it from the bottom up.
Really know that business.
Work there a few years,
insist on doing every job,
and one of these days, a light
is going on in your head,
and you're going to have
a really unorthodox idea,
an unmet need.
The way you find it,
is by burying yourself
in an industry you adore.
That's the way you
identify the unmet need,
and then, you have the germ of the idea
to start your own company.
- So what do you think?
- You know what, before
I got into the career
of dancing, running the dance school,
I wanted to be a marriage counselor,
so I went into psychology, I
started getting my education,
by working on my bachelor's.
Through it, I realized
that it wasn't for me,
then I changed career paths,
I wanted to be a police officer.
I became a security guard
to see what the night life,
night shift life, dealing with people
who are not necessarily always happy.
How was that?
I realized that, that wasn't for me,
and each of these career
choices, I went into the field
to see what it's like to
experience some part of it
and figure out if it's right for me.
With TDS, Toronto Dance
Salsa, it was the same thing.
I started as a student.
I went to become a helper-assistant.
I became an instructor, and
when I had the opportunity
to run, basically the business,
I realized that it was for me,
because of all of the
experience that I had
to see what it's like and the environment,
and I love the environment,
so why would I want to be somewhere else?
So, absolutely, I connect with them.
If you want to go into
a different industry,
if you want to start your own business,
see what it's like, see
what kind of experience
you can get, work for someone else.
If you want to be a lawyer,
and you want to open up
your own business, work
for a law firm, figure out
if that's the kind of
environment you want to have,
and then from there, you can figure out
do you want to open up your own law firm.
- Yeah, I've always
been a big believer that
you shouldn't just jump
full in on business.
Go work for somebody who's
done what you want to do.
Work for a company that
has 10 employees, or less,
in the industry that you want to be in,
and go work for them.
You're getting paid to learn.
You're getting paid to make mistakes.
You're getting paid to get
connections in the industry.
Normally, you pay to go to school.
Here you're getting paid to do it,
and you're going to make all the mistakes
on somebody else's dime,
and then when you're ready
to start your own company,
you have the connections,
you have the experience.
One of the reasons why I know so much more
about entrepreneurship, is
after I sold my first business,
I only had one company, it was
a biotech software company.
When I sold it, I joined
a venture capital company,
and it was these guys who
were in their 60s or 70s,
and I was this young
punk kid joining them,
and they taught me a lot about
all sorts of different businesses.
You know, everyday, we had
new companies comin' in,
and I was able to kind of
leech off of their decades
of collective experience,
to learn how different
industries are run, and it
got me there so much faster
than if I was just tryin'
to do everything myself.
So, I love the idea, if
you're just starting up,
and you want to get into businesses,
you can start your business on the side,
but go work for a company that
you respect and look up to,
that you want to be like
in a couple of years,
learn as much as you can
from them and when you have
enough money from your own thing,
that you can afford to quit your job
and go do that full-time,
that's when you make the leap.
So the question of the day, today, is?
- Would you be willing to take a pay cut
to work for someone who's
the expert in the industry
that you're thinking of
breaking into, and why?
- I like it.
Leave it in the comments below,
we will join in the discussion.
Also finally, want to
give a quick shout-out
to Jean-Phillipe Delisle.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really, really, really appreciate it,
and I hope your enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching!
We believe in you!
We hope you continue
to believe in yourself!
- Wrong way!
- Believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another --
- Shot of Entspresso!
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
(keys typing)
- If you want to be successful
in starting a business,
then you study what people have learned,
and everything that people have learned,
they've written down,
or shared in seminars
or put onto audio programs.
I learned this from a very wise man
named, Kopmeyer, who
spent more than 50 years
studying success, and he
had developed more than
1,000 success principles
that he had derived
out of something like 6,000 books,
and when I met him, I asked
him the question you would ask,
"Of all these thousand principles,"
'cause I had studied it all,
"Which is the most important
principle of all?",
and he said, "Brian",
he said, "It's simple."
He said, "Use proven success methods."
He said, "Learn from the experts."
He said, "Brian, you'll
never live long enough
"to learn it all for yourself."
So what I find, is that successful people
are those who learn
from other's who've gone
before them.
Unsuccessful people try to make it all up.
Like a cook going into the kitchen,
taking ingredients out of the cubbard,
throwing them all in a bowl,
and wondering why it doesn't taste good.
This why people's sales careers,
why 80 percent of
salespeople are functioning
well below their potential.
Only 20 percent make all the money,
why 20 percent of
businesses in any industry
make all the profits,
why 20 percent of the
professionals in any service
make 80 percent of the money, and so on,
it's because they follow
proven success principles.
Proven recipes, proven
formulas, proven combinations,
and they just do them over and over again,
until they master them.
Then they can do more and more of them,
faster and faster, easier
and easier at a higher level
of quality, and all that translates into
greater results.
- [Interviewer] Did not have
the rich dad in your life,
what would you be doing today?
- It's hard to say if I
didn't have my rich dad,
because as a young kid, starting probably
at the age of five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
I really wanted to be rich.
So I think number one is desire, you know,
and then you naturally seek
your role models and teachers,
and in my lifetime, I've
had multiple rich dads.
You know, my rich dad was
my best friend's father,
starting at the age of nine,
and then today, I still
seek mentors and wise men
and wise women, because
that's how you get wiser,
is by hanging out with smart people.